you remember this is the puzzle we were
wrestling with yesterday
and settle on an answer it might not
satisfy you as much as
you'd like it to but i was happy with it
by the end and i hope
it'll leave you with directions for
where to go in for future questions
just to get your head back into space
right we're
trying to get this idea of resistance
which is usually
proportional to right and then you get
these two alternatives
i might be velocity or might be the
square of the velocity being in either
case it tends to be quite
ambiguous because the question doesn't
talk at all about
mass when it talks about the
proportionality relationship right so
you kind of have to
do some guesswork as to whether you're
proportional or equal to mkb
or mkv squared i should say minus right
because it's going to be
in the opposite direction to the motion
or if you just sort of
disregard mass and you say
it's minus kv or minus kv
squared so which one do you go with or
which ones do you go with
um the short answer is
you sometimes go with all of them okay
now the question is
how do you know when you go to one when
you go
to the other so that's what i'm gonna
settle for you today now the first thing
to realize is that there's two there's
two ways i have to
sort of address this for all of us okay
two ways we have to address this
number one is in terms of how do you
understand this like just in terms of
do you remember we did this thought
experiment yesterday and we thought
about well okay
if mass increases for instance if we
bring it into play
mass increases should resistance
increase like you could pose that
question to yourself right so this is
about understanding
what do the equations mean what
significance do they have to the
when we work out all the equations and
so on okay now i think that's more
important
the answer to that question is well i
think some of you might have mentioned
this yesterday
um it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
i'll tell you what have a look at these
let's just consider these two cases okay
remember what m and k
what they represent okay k is some
constant of proportionality right so
we've got you know
k is some real number and almost
certainly
because we want to preserve the fact
just like in exponential growth and
decay
that it's resisting it's going it's
opposing the motion
we also usually say that it's positive
okay so
it's some constant whatever okay but now
think about what mass is
we're always thinking about objects that
are of constant
mass right i mean i suppose there are
some objects that get
heavier or lighter as you progress
through time but usually not
right so therefore mass is also a
constant and it's also a
positive one okay so therefore when
you're comparing these two
expressions right because both of these
bits are constant
that means their product is also
constant
and their product is also positive right
so in other words now just um let me
take out this mass loading
in other words k the constant
proportionality
right or mk this constant which seems to
include mass
they exhibit exactly the same qualities
right
so if mass was some number like two
right
if you included it if you if you
factored it in like this okay
then your value for k would be exactly
half the size as it is if you didn't
include
mass but it'll just be a different
constant we don't usually worry about
what it is it's just
a constant okay so in terms of
understanding the situation like ah
should mass play a role or not
the answer is in terms of the equation
it doesn't matter
because they're both going to give you
some constant it'll just be
the constant will be bigger or smaller
and we don't care okay
so i think that's the most important
thing do you understand what's going on
but the more
urgent thing is well that's nice
but how do i answer the questions right
like that's philosophically kind of
fancy but which approach should i
actually take okay
so i've got um i've got four criteria
here for you
and maybe you can jot them down with me
as to how you judge which one you should
use okay
four criteria let me just get some dot
points
okay so the first thing to recognize and
i went and i
did some research okay is that
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly right
they define it for you if you see a
question
right and in the hsc where it's um you
know
there's no opportunity for um you and me
to clarify or have a look at the answers
and check what they are really after
all you get is the question right and so
i'll read you a whole bunch of examples
that i picked out let's see here we go
let's have a look at the 2008 this is
the 2004
and it says something like okay i'll
read
a particle is released from the origin o
with initial velocity
it's directed vertically downward
there's resistance blah blah
okay the question before it gives you
the actual things it asks for it says
let the equation of motion be uh x
double dot
whoops
x double dot and then they give you this
ta-da right acceleration defined for you
so you could define
force from this couldn't you because
force is
ma right it's acceleration times mass
clearly what they're implying is you've
got f equals mg
minus m k v so in this case in the case
they've just defined for you
mass is included where in this case over
here does that make sense
they've defined it for you so you just
go on from there that's just one example
i wasn't satisfied with one because
i was like what if they are what if they
change the game on you later so i kept
looking
then i found other ones like for
instance
here we go um da da da
air resistance is kv it says assume air
resistance is kb so they define it for
you
that was the 1999 here's another one
uh let's see a ball is subject to
downward gravitational force of 20
newtons
and air resistance of v squared
on 5 newtons
right in the opposite direction to the
velocity and then they give you a result
you have to prove in fact they even go
further than that
they even go from that and they even
develop this for you
it's up and down so that's why they have
y
instead of x okay um
overwhelmingly like nine times out of
ten they just define it for you and you
never have to worry about this decision
okay so that's kind of a relief that's
really nice okay